[Music]
an important ally on an important
mission
the first official visit to Iran by the
Emir of Qatar chef Tamim bin Hamad
al-thani
comes at a critical time for the region
at the invitation of president Hassan
rouhani the two leaders discussed
increasing economic and political
cooperation considering the importance
of regional security especially in the
waterways in the Persian Gulf the Strait
of Hormuz and the sea of Oman we decided
to have more talks and cooperation for
the security of the whole region the
recent crisis between Iran and the
United States was also on the agenda
Qatar is one of a few countries in the
region that maintains a close
relationship with Washington and Tehran
30-feet what has this visit comes as a
very critical time in the region we've
agreed that the only solution is to
defuse escalations among all parties and
we've also agreed that dialogue and only
dialogue is the only route to any
solution to any crisis the Emir also met
Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei before ending his one-day visit
the supreme leader stressed
Tehran's readiness for wider cooperation
with regional states as the current
political climate is very sensitive in
the region because of US policies while
the diplomatic talks were underway this
was the scene outside the British
Embassy in Tehran the chants calling for
the embassy to be shut down on Saturday
the British ambassador Robert macare was
briefly arrested after attending what he
said was a vigil for the victims of
Iranian missile strike that brought down
a Ukrainian airliner killing 176 people
Iran's summoned the Ambassador accusing
him of attending an illegal protest
where demonstrators voiced their anger
at the initial denials that Iranian
forces had shut down the plane after
days of denials Iran's Revolutionary
Guard finally admitted mistakenly
shooting down the Boeing 737 on
Wednesday morning the British Foreign
Office described the ambassador
as a breach of international law he's
now joining calls for dialogue to reduce
tensions and finding a diplomatic way
forward the Qatari Emir is visit here is
being seen as the first sign of a real
diplomatic effort to ease the
hostilities between Iran and the United
States but it's too early to say whether
or not it will have the desired outcome
Dorsett Jabari al-jazeera Tehran well
Faisal istra body has served as a Rock's
ambassador to the United Nations and he
says that Iran is being compelled from
both inside and out to ease the crisis I
think everyone in the region wants a
de-escalation rather than an escalation
of the tensions of some of the reports
are true that even includes Iran and I
believe it also includes the President
of the United States there may be those
around him who want an escalation with
Iran but I don't think the president now
wants to be involved in another war in
the Middle East so I think a way forward
makes sense through intermediaries and I
think the Emir of Qatar than obvious
place to go for that sort of
intermediation the issues of course are
more complicated now before it was the
from the Iranian prospective sanctions
and the fact that the United States
withdrew from the nuclear agreement the
United States wants to negotiate a
better nuclear agreement but it also
wants assurances about Iran's regional
activities which are detrimental to US
interests and often detrimental to the
states involved such as Iraq such as
Lebanon but now with the with the
assassination of Qasem Soleimani
I think those efforts will be much more
complicated it's possible that because
the Iranian regime is feeling
international pressure but also pressure
domestically that it may now find an
opportune time to to find a way to
deescalate